good morning Hank it's Tuesday can you
introduce yourself hi I'm Charlie
plumber and you play miles halter in the
Looking for Alaska TV show kiss me Denny
love the colonel
aka chip mark what is John like in real
life I think John is way funnier than
people think
and he has way more what we call the
kids call drip then you'd think he knows
about all the new music he knows about
he's very hip which I was shocked about
I don't I don't think I have that much
drip because I don't know it's 21
savages I do like that song a lot
I find it relatable because I also have
a lot of water oh do you when did you
first read it I read the book when I was
15 oh I've never had that experience
before where I've read something and
then really so passionately want to be a
part of it and wanted to play a specific
character and now I'm getting to live
that and that's pretty unreal and I
think too much about it sometimes I
didn't read the book I'm so sorry so I
got the audition and I think I read it
in less than a day and at that point I
knew I was like this story is special I
didn't know how big it was to the world
but to me I was like this story is you
special when Denny auditioned for the
colonel he memorized one of the
Colonel's monologues from the book we
just shot that oh yeah they sent that to
me and it was so beautiful it was that's
great wrenching I was like five never
gets a blade of Colonel I have to be
able to perform that like I have to what
is one trade of miles that you can
relate to too many what do you like most
about the colonel I think the colonel
has such a huge heart like he just cares
so much about people about this school
about this world I think a lot of people
are gonna see that in the show that the
colonel has so much heart if you could
pick your name the way Alaska picks her
name what would you pick I don't say my
nolo that was my name in Spanish that's
a good name
yeah means the romantic one oh yeah
Manolo but you know you get to pick your
name yeah yeah and it's class yeah I saw
Manolo I said no no I think I was Pierre
in French Charlie here
so basic I've never met a Manola but I
want you you all got an a do you know
about John's thing with Keanu oh yes
oh it's one of my favorite things about
John he's like Jesus - you know Jesus is
like Jesus to me more like John the
Baptist how old do you think John is oh
gosh why are you asking could you say it
just aim low okay I'm 38 poof yeah you
didn't name that low what how do you
have any favorite last words the last
last words in the book of my favorite
last words what's your favorite scene in
the book the barn scene is my favorite
because I feel like in that scene you
get to know everybody
no no high school that's a big deal
guitar Kylie like express your truths
here and pull that hard you can largely
people yeah still hard you got trust
them enough to say those things out now
and not be judged and not have people
look at you differently that's a really
big moment what is the meaning of life
oh my god who knows but I think that the
meaning of life is to learn I think the
meaning of life is love
what song enables you to perfectly
envision the atmosphere of Looking for
Alaska it's hard to pick one song but I
would say this song 29 Stratford
apartments by Bon Iver
my Looking for Alaska song is love love
like a mountain goats ships yeah I also
have that on my playlist when does the
show come out this show comes out
October 18th and it's eight episodes and
bin jabal yes all right write out the
date right watch Amol at once on the on
the hulu on the hulu Hank I'll see you
on Friday